c'est difficile de retrouver son chemin
mesdames et messieurs je suis le
capitaine jefferson cas liquide
je suis là ce soir pour vous apporter
les nouvelles de notre vaste on paye
pour raconter des histoires j'ai jamais
entendu parler d'un travail comme celui
là ce n'est pas un métier où on fait
fortune comme tu peux voir
[Musique]
je ne veux aucun mal
tu comprends ce que je dis domota
mais
il est écrit que ton nom et johanna les
hamburgers les indiens thons capturés
quand ils ont attaqué ta famille il y a
6 ans
sa mère son père et sa soeur d'été bref
il s'en va
elle a de la famille à castroville
capitaine pour coiffer tout ça
elle a besoin de rire et de rêver elle a
besoin de nouveaux s'ouvrir la route est
barrée
c'est la loi maintenant oui
gavi tais toi joan hart
moindre idée de la façon dont on
s'occupe de l'enfant
c'est une photographie
c'est ma femme
doit sûrement savoir monter à cheval
ça c'est un cheval
cheval
capitaine
c'est exactement ça capitaine
on raconte que c'est la captive de
wichita falls que voulez vous
combien vous voulez poèmes cet enfant
n'est pas à vendre
[Musique]
elle se prend pour une indienne
les à moitié
mesdames et messieurs ce sont des récits
devant nous et de femmes qui vous
ressemble
attendent des jours meilleurs
les sésames
[Musique]